Einstein was the master of what we
usually call the thought experiment he
didn't go out into the world and
actually do experiments where he would
measure things and try to determine how
a given experiment would turn out
instead he would sit more or less at a
desk or work at a blackboard and through
the power of thought recognize that
there were certain puzzles that needed
to be resolved and the one that really
was vital to his understanding of
special relativity as this he recognized
that previous work that came to him from
the late 1800s works of someone named
James Clark Maxwell that work showed
that the speed of light seemed to be
constant that it seemed to be
unalterable now many people struggle
with that how could the speed of
something be unalterable and you take a
baseball you can change its speed you
throw it fast you threw it slow it can
go at different rates
why would light have a fixed speed
Einstein took that little puzzle very
seriously and realize well if speed is a
measure of how far something goes space
it covers divided by how long it takes
to get there a duration of time he
realized that if speed was constant for
light then space and time had to adjust
themselves in order that speed stayed
fixed space and time had to behave in a
way that was unfamiliar I'm gonna
thought that through in detail he
realized that space can shrink and time
can dilate depending upon how you were
moving and that's how he came to these
rather shocking realizations about space
and time